last week we focused on just finding the
secondary just just calculate it and
also what's the secondary who's supposed
to tell you and we said the first trivet
is about gradient like go to your
geometry and shape first two is about
gradient second derivative is about
concavity so we introduced this idea
that you know rather than going up or
going down
increasing or decreasing or neither
stationery ku cavity is about thinking
about the curvature in which way it's
facing okay so for example this is an
increasing function here's an increasing
function here's another increasing
function okay but when you think about
these three good morning when you think
about each of these three even though
they're all increasing they are all
increasing in different ways okay for
instance this guy here he's increasing
at a constant rate straight line yeah
this one's increasing and it's getting
faster
this one's increasing and it's getting
slower right so in terms of concavity we
would say this guy is concave up this
guy is concave down what's lurking carry
a backpack we haven't thought too much
about this but you can logic it out how
would you describe it scream cavity well
yeah you see what I said I'll think
about its curvature and which way it
curves well then this guy doesn't have
any curvature right like I can't say oh
yes the cup is face up or its face down
this is there is gonna come right now
this um this by the way it is a more
formal way that you cannot determine
that this is a straight line right so
for example it might have an equation
like y equals MX plus B okay now we can
work out fairly easily what the first a
second derivative of this line is going
to be what's the first derivative it's
the gradient right and then when you go
ahead and you work out the second
derivative remembering the M is just a
constant like that's what makes it a
straight line right what's the second
derivative is zero so all about to say
you've got good morning concave up means
the second derivative is positive okay
concave down means the second
negative but this is not a positive nor
negative right it doesn't really have a
KU cavity so you can have these
different classes of increasing
functions you can have the same thing
for decreasing and that's what we focus
on as the that's what it means
that's what the second area actually
looks like and what it tells you now
we're going to focus on using this
equity as a tool to work out other
things about the features of our graph
okay
so we're going to focus on two main
areas I'm the first one is one that you
already know about which is stationary
points okay so we're going to talk about
stationed in front so you can see if we
have a look at this question it maps out
really easily for Reta with me if f of x
equals this is function find f - right f
double dash
hence find any stationary points and by
examining the sign of the second
derivative determine their nature
remember that was that phrase before
fine stationary points so you solve for
the first derivative being zero and then
determine their nature how did we
determine the nature of a stationary
point before yeah we use that table of
values you look on the left you look on
the right we talked about how to pick
those values and then you see what kind
of shape you're getting or do this or do
you get the idea okay
now that we have the second derivative
we have a more powerful tool or a more
efficient tool for finding and
determining these ages so let's go ahead
and do this right first on is we're
gonna need the first derivative and you
can just read up the first derivative
from this graph right from this equation
it's going to be three expert takeaway
free fantastic okay now at this point I
say because they said find any
stationary points where are stationary
points it's where the first derivative
is zero okay so I'm going to say
stationary points exist when f dash x
equals zero okay I'm just gonna again
remind you these these little connecting
sentences are critically important
pretty clear what they convey that you
know what's going on and they make sure
that you just have the strees
series of equations that are strung
together for no apparent reason okay so
this is what I'm solving for so I say
you know what that actually is
three x squared minus 3 equals zero you
can go ahead and you can solve this
wholly or what you do thank you take out
a factor of three in fact because I've
got zero on the right hand side I'll
just divide through fine and so from
here I have two solutions like you don't
even need a baptize this Steve what am i
two solutions plus an minus one okay so
there are my X values I've found the
stationary points yet I only need some Y
values that would go with those so I'm
gonna come back up here right and I'm
going to say well I have language for
this I can say f of one that's going to
be my y coordinate right will be one
cubed minus three which is minus two and
then F of negative one which is my other
stationary point it's going to be
that'll be minus one plus three which is
okay which shouldn't be that surprising
because even if you didn't spot it
before one kind of symmetry does this
function have it's an odd function you
can easy it's all there all all the
powers odd because this is an easy way
of saying okay good so what do I do now
I have found where the stationary points
are I haven't said it yet because I'm
gonna tie it off in a nice bow but I
grow station point 1 minus 2 and the
stationary point at minus 1/2 question I
can't get well what am I gonna do next
okay good so I'm I want to determine the
nature of these stationary points by
using the second route now just remember
why this works ok this is the picture
that we're getting this is a picture
Guinea concave up concave down okay if I
have a local maximum then what is the
concave er going to be for that point
the actual action it's going to be
concave down right so if I find that the
second derivative is negative I will
conclude that's a maximum and of course
in Reverse if I have a minimum then at
that exact point it should be concave up
ok so if I have a positive second
derivative I will conclude it's a
minimum
okay so in order to do any of that I
need to know what the second derivative
is over here yeah Double Dash is equal
to can you read it off for me 6x that's
just it isn't it because that negative
three doesn't figure into the second
review okay so now that I know what F
Double Dash is everywhere I want to know
what it is at these particular points
all right so I'm gonna say F Double Dash
of one right well if the function is
just six X so it's C's okay now does the
market is carefully what's the way I'm
gonna set this out okay
what I'm interested in is the sign of
this guy right
good morning the sign of this right I've
established by getting a number the
number is important just like it was
when we were doing the table of values
okay it's it's I could say therefore f
double dash of 1 is greater than zero
I've made a statement about its sign
right now this is about the sign of the
second derivative now I'm going to
interpret that geometrically
I'm gonna say ie second derivative
positive so it's concave up concave up
that phrase is important I am show me
that I know geometrically what the
secondary algebraically is saying yes so
which of these is concave up which way
the cup is facing right so this is
concave up
it's a minimum because it's concave up
but in a second our drawer to convince
you I'm testing I'm testing F Double
Dash of one isn't one and six
so one one is the x-coordinate
that's one crease and six is what I've
got as the second derivative right so
that's my coordinate there right but my
second derivative is this okay stay with
me stay with me I'm not finished yet
it's okay let's see let's see how we go
as we progress through it okay it's
concave up which means therefore now I'm
going to draw a conclusion okay and I'm
gonna bring together all the things that
I've said one is the x coordinate
negative two is the y coordinates or say
1 comma negative 2 is a now I'll
classify it right it's concave up that
looks like a minimum to me right so I'm
gonna say it's a minimum turning point
yeah yeah okay so and by the way this is
a part of the importance of why I
actually say this right lots of students
who try to eat it or that like we try to
save time basically and then we do this
if you do that kind of like a 50/50
chance of the particular question of a
particular marker really Carrie it's
okay I get what you're talking about
okay however that means you have a 50/50
chance of it mattering in the question
right or the Marcus a nota that's a
particular point of differentiation
between the students that I'm mocking so
that's why I'm going to say it's really
important to actually state that because
it's a connection from here here right
it's not that the sign of the second
derivative tells you what kind of
turning point is it's that King candy
tells you what the turning point is and
there's like a is like a step persistent
- okay so I've done it once I'm just
gonna do it a second time for the other
turning point that I've found so I'm
going to go - sorry a double - on
negative one because I already have I
say can you do there it's maybe or six
therefore the second derivative at that
point is negative ie it's concave down
okay so now I'll tie it up in a neat row
by bringing together the coordinates at
the point with what I've determined
about its nature - one combo - is a
okay so any questions on that does that
make sense again I think that this is
the pretty cool spot in here and you can
see I've got F and F Dash and F Double
Dash all flying around which is why it's
important to house sentence is
connecting everything so you see what's
going on okay all right now this is how
we use the second derivative for
determining the nature of staging point